- Hi, everyone, welcome to the
Daily Homeroom live stream.
I'm Sal Khan from Khan Academy.
For those of you all who are new to this,
this is a Homeroom that
we are doing every day,
as the name implies, to
really stay connected
during these times of school closures.
Khan Academy, we realize
that we have a role,
we have a duty to step up when
we saw the schools closing.
And we said how can we
better support parents,
teachers, students around the
country and around the world
in these really hard times.
It's we've been running parent
webinars, teacher webinars,
putting together all of our
content from early learning.
We're gonna talk a lot
about early learning today
from early learning all
the way through elementary,
middle and high school and ways,
learning plans and schedules
that can help folks.
And then also to do this so
that we can stay connected
and answer folks questions in
kind of a live synchronous way
in this time of social distancing.
I do remind everyone that Khan Academy
is a non profitable organization.
We can only exist through
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in our position to do so
please think about making
a donation to Khan Academy,
every donation matters.
I wanna give special thanks
to several corporations
that have stepped up in
the last several weeks.
As soon as they saw the
COVID crisis was happening,
they said, hey, we wanna make sure that,
you can stay up and running.
We were running a deficit
even before the crisis
and we continue to run a deficit.
But the support from these organizations
have made a big difference
Bank of America, AT&T,
Google.org, Novartis and
Fastly, thank you so much.
And if any of you can are
representing corporations,
please reach out to us
I'm khan@khanacademy.org
anyone can email me there.
If you think you have an
interesting way for us
to get sustainable cause you can imagine,
we're already running in a
deficit and then the crisis
our traffic is about three
x of what it typically is,
we're trying to do more programs,
so we, we need that support.
So I am super excited
about our guest today,
we've had her on before.
But she's got several really
exciting announcements
that I have to say, I was just
telling Caroline before this,
I'm quite enthusiastic, I'm quite excited
about some of the stuff
she's gonna talk about.
So Caroline, maybe I'll
let you take the floor,
you know, you have a
couple of announcements.
Tell us what's new at Khan Academy Kids.
Or actually remind folks
what Khan Academy Kids is,
and then tell us what's new.
- Sounds good, yep.
So I lead the Khan Academy Kids team,
which is a program for children
ages two through seven,
so preschool through grade one.
And it's a comprehensive
early learning program
that covers multiple subjects,
everything from academic
subjects like reading, and math
and also social emotional development
and executive function skills.
And our app includes thousands
of lessons, and books,
and interactive activities
that kids can learn from.
And so there is an adaptive learning path
that adjusts to a child's level.
And then there is a library,
that has the thousands of lessons in it.
And today, we have a lot of new things
that we've been working on.
One is a big research
study was just announced,
and I can go through that.
And then we also are announcing
our teacher tools launch
in Khan Academy Kids version three.
- So a lot of good news
here, so first of all,
tell us about the research study.
- Sure, so it was very important for us
to get an independent
academic study on our program,
to test the effectiveness of it.
And we did a study with
Professor David Arnold
from the University of
Massachusetts in Amherst,
and he just released his results publicly.
And the study was a randomized
control trial study,
which is the gold standard
of academic studies.
Were there two groups of
randomly selected students,
and one group gets the Khan
Academy Kids intervention
and one get is the control group.
And so this was a study
of four and five year olds
prior to entering kindergarten.
And they were from low income families
with an median annual
income of about $24,000.
And so what we saw was
that in a 10 week study,
the kids that were using Khan Academy Kids
saw substantial increases in
their pre literacy skills.
So they were tested pre test,
with the test of preschool
early literacy, TOPEL test.
And then post test and we saw the gains
were really substantial.
They were at the beginning of the study
about upper 34th percentile likely,
due to the effects of poverty.
And then after the 10 weeks
of using Khan Academy Kids
for 20 minutes a day.
They were close to the national
average at 47th percentile.
And so the size of these
gains are substantial,
they're equivalent to
what is typically found
in much more expensive intervention.
So as an example, the phonological gains
were comparable to those found
in an intervention of 25,
one to one sessions with
a professional tutor.
- I mean there's a lot
of what you've just said
that I think is worth
unpacking and underlining.
I mean, just the first thing is,
10 weeks is not a lot of time,
it's your point it was 20 minutes per day.
And that essentially closed
the gap between the students
who are performing a good bit,
below where they need to be.
And getting essentially
to the national average,
if I heard that correctly.
- Right because students,
particularly low income students,
often enter the first day of kindergarten
and they're already behind
in these critical pre literacy skills.
Which are things like recognizing
letters of the alphabet,
understanding letter sounds,
knowing their letter sounds,
and understanding
phonological awareness skills,
being able to break down
sounds and words and sentences.
So these are really critical
to learning how to read.
So they start school behind
and then they don't catch up.
- Now, I was super excited.
I mean, this is one of
those things where I'm,
obviously this is part of Khan
Academy's Khan Academy Kids.
But Caroline and her team
are a bit of a mini team on their own.
And so I sometimes I don't
know about these things
until I her them, and it was
really, really heartening.
You know, we always
had an intuitive sense,
this was really valuable.
And I have to say, you know, Caroline,
I was telling you this
before we got on the call.
I have a five and a half
year old, as many folks know.
And, you know, people might say, oh,
Sal's five and a half year old,
he must be super motivated,
in academics, no he likes to dance a lot,
and you know, and make potty humor.
And my wife says he got that from me.
I don't know, I think
I'm quite sophisticated,
but he's been on it so much.
And, you know, so intuitively as a parent,
I got to say it feels right.
It is incredibly engaging for children,
but it's not your just
your classic edutainment,
it is true standards aligned.
Tell us about kind of
the work that's put in,
to make sure that it is standards aligned
and engaging at the same time.
- So Khan Academy Kids,
each of our lessons
is aligned with national standards.
So for preschool, it's the headstart
early learning outcomes
framework for literacy and math.
And then for kindergarten and first grade,
it's the Common Core Standards.
And we've worked with educators
from the Stanford Ed school,
who are who specialized in early learning
and child development.
To make sure that our lessons
are aligned with standards
and also taught in a way that reflects
how really experienced
teachers teach these concepts
in the real world.
And what we've learned through
looking at the research
on the learning of science learning,
is that technology has the power
to really further the
learning for children
if it meets certain criteria.
So it has to be active
hands on engaging learning,
it has to give kids
specific real time feedback.
And then it also needs to adjust
to a child's individual level.
And that's what we've
built Khan Academy Kids
around those principles.
- And I wanna emphasize to
folks, this is all free,
this is all non for profit.
And I think a lot of people are skeptical
about things like this, they're
like, there must be a catch.
I mean, people have thought
that about Khan Academy,
but there's other resources out there,
that are more than happy to charge you,
you know, five dollar month,
$10 a month, you know,
buy an app for this amount.
And, you know, anyone
who doesn't believe me
go download the app and put
it in front of a two, three,
four, five, six or seven
year old and you will see,
not only does it work
and keep them engaged
and is very good for them,
but it has a lot more in it
than you would normally expect of an app.
I mean, you touched on it there's
a ton of stories in there,
ton of activities.
- Yeah, that's what we've
been hearing from parents
is that it's particularly during this time
of remote learning.
They are relieved to find something
that is so comprehensive.
And actually they can see
their children building
their vocabulary, learning how to count.
I think we've heard we
hear directly from parents
who are saying that they didn't realize
that technology could
teach their child so much.
But they're in these desperate situations,
they found Khan Academy Kids,
and now after just a few
days or weeks of using it,
they're realizing that their kids
are really building these skills.
And it's not only the academic skills
that are so important for this age,
as Sal was saying, his
son is wants to play
And so all kids at this age want to play.
So the way that we approach
learning is play based,
and entertaining, as well
as engaging for kids.
Is like they wanna learn
through stories and songs.
And that's those are really, through play
is how kids build some of
those critical early numeracy,
vocabulary and literacy skills.
- And I do wanna remind
folks, if you have questions,
start putting your questions
on YouTube and Facebook
on the message boards.
We have team members looking at them,
I will get them to Caroline
over the course of our conversation.
But there's a few more things
I wanna just make sure I have a chance
to talk to Caroline about.
I mean, I do wanna double down on this.
You know, my wife is a physician
and she was on physician,
some physician moms group.
And people were talking
about this age group,
and people saying what should I use,
and a lot of parents were saying
a lot of physician moms were
saying Khan Academy Kids,
it's incredible, it's free,
and it has way more than you think.
But there are other people who are saying,
oh, you know, this thing that
I pay $10 a month for my wife
is like, I can't believe
people are paying money.
When this is available, especially
and some of that stuff you pay money for.
It's not as engaging, it's
not as standards aligned
and it doesn't have the
types of efficacy studies
that you just talked about.
And look, you and I are
not selling anything.
We are funded with
philanthropic donations,
and I'll say please donate so
that we can keep doing this.
But I you know, if you have young kids
you shouldn't have to pay for this.
And if you know people, the
young kids make sure they know
that this stuff is
available there for free.
You know, we don't have the
marketing budget to tell,
you know, to put ads out on the world.
But this is there free and
most high quality resource.
Caroline, tell us about the other,
I mean, there's the announcement around
some of your teacher
tools, tell us about that.
And I actually also wanna make sure
people know about some of
the first grade content
you've added recently as well.
Tell us about what you're
doing for teachers.
- Sure, so right before school closures
at the beginning of March,
we launched a large update
to Khan Academy Kids
that included all of the
Common Core Standards
for first grade, ELA and math.
And then after school
closures on the heels of that,
we decided to fast track
our teacher tools update.
So we have just in the last
week announced our teacher tools
and this was really important for us
because since the beginning teachers
have been Claromentis Khan Academy Kids
and they've actually been,
which was originally designed
for families and parents.
So parents set up an account
and so teachers were actually
using the home accounts
to set up their students.
But it really wasn't designed
to support a whole class.
And so these teacher tools include,
easy ways for teachers
to set up their class
with the teacher and students.
And then to look at search all
of our lessons by standards,
so the standards that
they're teaching tool,
they can find the relevant lessons,
and then assign lessons to their students.
And then after their students
have done some of the lessons,
they can monitor how
their students are doing.
So which students have
completed these lessons,
how they're doing, what the scores are,
and they can look at the
assignments by assignment,
or they can look at the
scores by student as well.
- Go ahead.
- And this remote learning
there, we've made it easy
so that teachers can just share
a code with parents at home.
So that the students can learn at home,
on their devices at home,
and then the teachers can
continue to send them assignments
and monitor their progress.
And this is so important in this age,
because students really
need that connection
with their teacher, and the
teachers know best about
what this their individual
students need to be learning.
- Now, I wanna emphasize that,
one parents could also
use that functionality.
And if you know, as I
was a couple days ago,
I was like, where is this functionality
that Caroline and Michael had showed me?
And I was like, oh, I have
to update the app (chuckles)
Reminder, update the app,
and then you will see
this functionality and
there is instructions.
Where can people find instructions,
if they wanna understand
and how do they activate
the teacher tools?
Or how do they assign things?
If you just go to khankids.org,
we will have a link to our teacher tools.
And we have modules like Quick Setup Guide
and things like that, to walk you through
each of the different steps.
- Yeah, and I gotta say,
it's quite powerful,
you're able to just look
at the entire library thing
by standards, by grade level,
and then just you can
sample it very nicely
and say, oh, I can assign
this to my students.
And, you know, we, I've been talking
to the my five year old teachers
and it is amazing, it's
almost the exact, you know,
I think they're very thoughtful
about what my five year old
needs to be doing right now.
But you know, but they're doing,
they were doing primarily those,
you know kind of classic worksheets.
But the stuff that y'all have done,
cover those same standards
in so much more of an engaging
way and interactive way.
And he frankly wants you know,
it's a bit of pulling teeth
to get my son to do even
one worksheet on you know,
in theory that could take
him like three minutes to do
but like, you know, a
long versus short oh,
and I'm like, let's just doing
it, just you know (laughs)
But same activity on Khan Academy Kids
he like wants to do it after
kind of pull him off of it.
So, you know, if you can't
tell I'm very excited
about the work of Caroline.
(laughing)
- We're really heartened
in this time I think,
you know, there is risk of
academic loss during this time,
without teachers and being in school,
and so this is why we're so
motivated to do this work.
But we're so heartened to
see all the kids and parents
that are writing into us
with stories about how they
are just hungry to learn
and they love learning and
they're sending us their stories
and they're sending us their
photos of the activities
that they're doing.
- Yep, there is two
questions here from Facebook,
Scott Yang says, hey, Sal,
why didn't you put the
big bear behind you today?
You know what, Scott, I'm gonna do that,
I'm gonna go get Cody.
I was told I had to be
on, I think it was CNN
and one member of our team says,
well, you know, Cody bear
looks like he's just
kind of staring at you.
So that's why I took it off.
So I'm gonna get that but while,
I actually I'm gonna get that right now,
but I'm gonna give a question
from Andrea Adams Midget
from Facebook.
How can I ensure, this is for Caroline,
how can I ensure my
five and seven year old,
do not get addicted to tech
during this time of homeschooling online?
And I'm gonna go get Cody.
- Sure I look forward to seeing Cody,
that is a great question.
I think at the top of our minds,
we designed Khan Academy Kids
to make sure that it was
developmentally appropriate.
And not to focus on using technology
for hours and hours on end.
It's designed for kids to be using
in five to 10 to 20 minute increments
depending on their age and
what's appropriate for them.
So some ways that we've
done that is, there is Cody
in designed activities,
so that after a lesson
you are coming back out
and the lessons are paced
to be short increments
with an introductory video
and then highly active
interactive experiences.
And then after a few activities
will tell your kids to
get up and sing this song
or dance and so, or go outside
and take a look at the leaves
or something like that
related to the story.
So we really are cognizant
of not having it,
be an experience that
just sucks your kids in.
Which a lot of adult
technology as we all know
from social media, and all that
is designed to be addictive.
So we're on the congress designed to be,
hands on, minds on learning,
but not sucking your kids in.
You can kind of tell when
they get that glazed over look
for things that are not active learning.
And so we designed it to
be active and interactive.
Another thing is, I think
just being we have come out
with some schedules for kids
just as a starting point.
And every family is different
and has different routines,
but having some structure
to the day does help,
particularly with young
children and them knowing okay,
we're gonna have reading time
now, and then in half an hour,
we are gonna go outside and play.
And so understanding that regular routine
and that those transitions
that are coming up
can really help.
We really advocate balancing
not only the Khan Academy Kids
all time, but all the other learning
that they're doing outside
and inside the house.
And we'd come up with some
programs to support that as well,
we believe in offline learning
and have some printables
on our website, as well as activities
that you can do with
materials in your house.
And then Sophie and I from my
team are hosting a circle time
where we encourage kids
to get up and dance
and we read books with them
and do interactive activities
that also highlight the types of learning
that are in Khan Kids.
- And I'll say, just as a parent,
and you know, this is literally something
that I observed this
morning, and last night.
Is, you know, when my son is on a device,
he looks, you know, I don't
know if you can see me
right now, but you know, he
looks kind of like a fleet,
you know, he kind of
has this like, you know,
when he is just like watching
YouTube, he's just like this,
you know and no parent wants to see that,
on their kid too long
where he's just you know, staring at it.
But when he is doing Khan Academy Kids,
there is something about it,
where he's like, yes,
and he is moving around,
and he is dancing.
And he is like, I don't know what it is,
but I definitely seeing him,
it's kind of feels like healthier behavior
than you know, the just like,
you know, tablet, zombieism
that you sometimes see.
And, you know, what I would add is,
you know, no one is advocating
to do this hours a day.
I think your research
study was 20 minutes a day,
so, you know, I could imagine
a couple of 10, 15 minutes
a day sessions, it's plenty
to keep people progressing.
And if you need time, where
your kids on the screen,
this is a very healthy screen time.
- Yeah, we've designed
it so that Cody bear
the one behind Sal talks to your child,
and we've scripted the
language, open ended question
so that kids that's why the
kids are talking back to the app
and tell, you know,
talking about, you know,
what their thinking and their learning.
- Yeah, there's just this morning,
we my son was doing the
subjects of sentence
and you know, it was like, you know,
he wrote a bicycle to town
and it had a picture of Cody
or a little cartoon of
Cody riding a bicycle.
And I was like, you know,
it says, what's the subject
and you could tell he was
probably processing it,
cause the, you know, obviously was he,
and he's like Cody's riding a bike.
I guess Cody is he.
You know, it was just really
powerful for me to see
that, process going on I actually thought,
you know being able to identify subjects
or kind of verbs in a sentence
was a little bit beyond him
at the stage he is in.
But I was very, very impressed
with how the app delivered it.
So more questions here, so this
is Dave Hankin from YouTube
says as a teacher, I'd like to know
how you recommend
introducing Khan Academy Kids
to parent guardians, so
they'll buy into regular use.
- As a teacher, I think
now with our teacher tools,
it would be a lot easier
to get them to buy into regular use,
particularly if you send them
an assignment or two a day.
Then they will know
they're getting something
from their teacher and
the students will be able
to see that assignment in there view,
and you'll be able to see
which ones they've completed
and and how they've been done.
And doing these assignments
is really quick,
you can just search by standard
or even just look through our library
and see which lessons are aligned
with what you would like to teach
and then just press a
button and it's assigned.
- Yeah, I have to say, you know what,
what I've seen for my
own children's school
is they've been doing a heroic job,
they have a learning management system.
And they, you know,
they sent us printouts,
so but every morning me or my wife,
we have to go print out the worksheets,
then my child does them,
then we got to take pictures of them.
We texted, uploaded onto
the learning manager,
it's quite stressful for us some days.
But you could imagine now
with Khan Academy Kids,
you can as a teacher, assign it,
and parents and families and students
just have to get in the habit of like,
hey, in the morning,
let's see what's assigned.
And then they can go through that,
they don't have to upload pictures
and all this other stuff that
you have to do with worksheets
in this time of social distancing.
So yeah, I think as a teacher,
you have a lot of power to
forget to get families on it.
So a related question Lauren
Buyer from Facebook asks,
would any of the teacher platform tools
be useful for parents to use at home?
- Absolutely, so it
particularly during this time
when all of you are home schoolers.
Absolutely, if you want
to use Khan Academy Kids
teacher tools, all you need
to do is set up an account
as a teacher.
Or if you're a parent, and
you already have an account,
you can convert it from
the parent section,
we have some documentation on
our website on how to do that.
- From Facebook, Scott Yang asked,
and I can help answer this as well.
But Caroline, who helped you oh, actually,
I read this the wrong way, but I'll answer
what I read it the first way.
But Caroline, tell us a little bit about
how Khan Academy Kids was
founded, is what Scott is asking.
I read funded the first time
I was gonna answer that too.
But you go.
- Well, so I founded a company
called Duck Duck Moose,
about 10 years ago with
my husband, Michael.
And we created 21 educational apps
for mostly preschoolers
and elementary school,
early elementary school.
And we did this independently
for about eight years,
and then in 2016, we joined Khan Academy.
So we have been part of
Khan Academy since 2016,
and focused on now on
developing Khan Academy Kids.
Although the Duck Duck Moose
apps are still out there,
and they've been downloaded,
I think over 60 or 70 million times.
- Yeah, for I've oftentimes espoused
my benevolent alien theory,
that benevolent aliens
are using Khan Academy
as a vector to prepare
humanity for first contact.
And when Caroline and Michael reached out,
yes, yes, it's been a while
now four years ago and said,
we you know, they all had a presentation.
It was kind of hilarious
and I was like, no, no,
I know all about you all.
I'm your biggest fan,
my kids are, you know,
been using Duck Duck Moose.
I've always told the Khan Academy team,
the only time we're ever
gonna get into early learning
is if we can be anywhere remotely
as good as Duck Duck Moose team.
And the fact that y'all
were in the office,
I was like, why are you here?
And then you and Michael
said, well, we'd actually
like to donate our
organization to Khan Academy.
And I was like, alright
benevolent aliens, thank you,
we get the message.
- Yeah, to your earlier point about
how we're completely free.
We couldn't do that when
we were not a nonprofit,
and when we were independent.
And so to us, it was so important for us
to be able to focus on the
deep education for kids
and not to interrupt kids
with in app purchases
and subscriptions while they're learning.
- And to give you, Michael
and the team, a lot of credit,
you had other financial options
where you guys could
have gotten bought out
and it could have been very,
very lucrative for y'all.
But this is something that you
just decided as humanitarians
that you wanted to, you
want your life's work
to be accessible to as
many people as possible.
And so Caroline, Michael and her team,
they passed up a lot of money
that a lot of us would
have thought twice about
in order to make Khan Academy
Kids not for profit ever.
And, you know, we were
able to, then obviously,
they were able to donate
their organization to us
which was frankly worth many millions,
arguably 10s of millions of dollars.
And, but then we had to go find funders
and that's where at the time
was called the Omidyar Network,
Pierre Omidyar, Pierre and Pam Omidyar,
founder of eBay, famously.
His foundation was one
of the major funders
that allowed us to do this work.
And then the Windsong Trust.
Those are the two really big funders
that allow us to this work.
But once again, we're also
running it as a deficit
at the Khan Academy Kids level.
So especially if you're a parent,
and you've really enjoyed it,
please think about donating.
And if you're a
corporation, or foundation,
please think about helping
us to support this work.
So from YouTube, Wendy Oliver.
This is more of a comment,
but it's a good comment.
The offline is a great
feature for those families
who are remote or do not
have access to the internet.
And Caroline, tell us more
about the offline functionality,
and you know what devices
can this be used on
if people just have a cell
phone, is that sufficient?
- Yes, so we designed Khan
Academy Kids to be accessible
as widely as possible on Android and iOS,
as well as across different
devices, phones and tablets.
And it was very important for us to design
so that folks with intermittent
Wi-Fi could use it.
So we have an offline mode,
where a substantial portion
of our content in early literacy
and math can be accessed
when you're offline.
So you can use all of those lessons,
for the complete library
and the learning path.
You do need an internet connection
just because of the thousands of lessons,
there is no way that we could
pack it into a mobile app,
nor would you want it all on your device.
But we've also designed the technology
so that it downloads in small packets
when you do need new lessons
for your learning path
and then it purchased them.
So it's really designed to be efficient
so that anybody on any
devices can use them.
- Yeah, and I think that's,
you know, does double download,
you know, we really
obviously, the whole reason
why Khan Academy exists,
Khan Academy Kids exists
is to level the playing
field as much as possible.
And there's all sorts
of inequity right now
in device access,
and we're trying to work
with others to solve it.
But Khan Academy Kids goes,
arguably further I mean,
the Khan Academy main app, so to speak
also has some ways to download content,
but y'all do a really great job.
It's as long as you have at
least a reasonable smartphone
and have some time to
download some of the materials
that that you can go pretty far.
There is a question about
from Susan Garcia Dominguez
on YouTube.
Is it available on laptops or
is it only tablets and phones?
- It is only on mobile devices right now,
and the reason for that is
that we found in testing
with young children that the
form factor of mobile devices
where they have the touchscreen
that they can directly manipulate
is much more effective for learning.
It's tough for the two year
old and three year olds,
to navigate, before they
can read on a computer
with a with a mouse.
- Yeah, and even the
five and six year olds.
I mean, they can do it kind of, but it's,
and that leads to another
question from Nikio on YouTube.
I feel like I know a lot of these folks
cause we have good question
askers who show up here,
Susanna, Nikio, Scott, almost every day.
But hi Sal, Caroline one of
the best studying methods
while simultaneously using Khan Academy.
You know, I'll interpret that
is how does Khan Academy Kids,
you know, transition to Khan Academy.
I have a view there, but
I'd love your take on
what it is today and what
could be in the future.
- Yeah, I think right
now, it's, we cover up
through the end of first grade
and then Khan Academy does take
we're hoping to scale up through
the end of second grade at least.
And then Khan Academy
takes over from there,
but we're building those
those critical skills,
in pre literacy and math before
you get into Khan Academy.
- Yeah, and if you go to Khan Academy,
there is content on
kindergarten, first grade,
second grade content, but it
does require to use a mouse.
And it has things like
select all that apply.
And so we view that content,
especially in a world
where Khan Academy Kids exists,
that's valuable if you're a
fourth grader, a third grader,
or if you have a student
who needs to remediate
some of that content or
review some of that content.
But ideally, if you are,
if you're working on
first grade standards, or
below Khan Academy Kids
is the place to go.
And yeah, I hope second
grade and you know,
third grade could be an
interesting thing too,
if we have the resources to do it,
to think about cause Khan
Academy Kids really is,
I think hitting the sweet
spot for all those kids needs.
I see that my own son when
I put them on Khan Academy,
they're using the mouse,
you know, the motor skills
to kind of click on the radio button
is a little bit more difficult,
than and obviously with Khan
Academy Kids, yes, no problem.
No problem at all.
See more questions I'm getting on,
so there is the other questions.
This is from Madeleine Bordwell on youtube
I love that you see the Super Simple songs
their interactive component
cheers to you and your team.
And that's a good reason to
talk more about all the content
and the partners that we've
been able to (mumbles).
- We're so grateful for the partners,
a lot of our content is homegrown.
So we have our own books
that are illustrated
by our own illustrators,
but we collaborate
with children's book
authors to author original
an original series of books.
And then we also collaborate
with Super Simple Songs,
which is an amazing
animation company that has,
I think, I don't know how many
billions of views on YouTube
but favorite nursery
rhymes and great animations
coupled with these songs.
And so we integrate them
into Khan Academy Kids
and then make them interactive.
So we'll use the Muffin Man song
and then have children do
activities around that.
In addition, we partner
with National Geographic
and bellwether which have
nonfiction books on animals
and nature and so that's how we have
some of our rocket science content.
- So more questions here,
Maria, he says from YouTube
Sal, are you okay, you look tired.
- (chuckles) Are you okay?
- I think it's just irrelevant
because Caroline looks so
energetic and well lit.
And yeah, I'm looking at
myself now, and I'm like,
yeah, that guy, he is something.
I think it's all relative I think
what you don't see Carolina I'm fine.
- Is my background, I do circle time here,
so I have to look weak and
you have a lot of energy.
- I think Maria is onto something
I need to introspect a little bit.
Rusika tell him Sadie from YouTube,
I literally did my Khan
Academy homework right now,
love the detail videos.
All that good to hear that Rusika.
Let's see other there is
someone, there is folks
Scott asking a lot of questions.
Hey, Caroline would you
like to invite Sophie
into a live stream and Sal someday?
I guess supporters yes,
we'd love to have Sophie.
- We would love Sophie everywhere.
- She will only reinforce me looking
like I'm tired and aging.
- Oh, yeah, she's another level.
She does all of our parent
and teacher webinars as well.
- Marie, you've confirmed
some of my insecurities,
so I don't know, I'm feeling a little.
I sometimes like to think that,
I'm more young and sprite than I am.
Let's see, there is a
lot of questions here,
but first, we're out of time.
I'm always I'm having a good
time with these conversations,
until someone points out
that I look old and tired.
But Caroline, tell us a little bit more.
I mean, what are your hopes, I
mean, just to finish this up,
what are your hopes and
dreams for Khan Academy Kids?
- Yeah, I think we are
just grateful right now
that we have a role to play in our way.
To help families and teachers
during this time in particular,
so we're kind of just very, very focused
on the current moment and
everything that we can do.
This new teacher tools is
extremely exciting for us to see
we are already seeing
districts and teachers use it,
from California all the
way across to New Jersey.
And I think we were just at the beginning
of our classroom entry,
and we'll continue that.
As well as with new features
for teachers and classrooms,
and then we're very excited
to continue with the content.
We're seeing the kids grow and
they wanna grow more with us,
and so, continuing on to second grade.
- Awesome, well, I just
wanna thank everyone
I wanna remind everyone
go try, Khan Academy Kids,
even if you don't have
early learners at home,
proselytize it tell other people
because it's a shame that, anyway,
tell them about Khan Academy (mumbles)
Tell so many families,
especially families of need
that don't realize that there
are resources out there,
for them and their children
and for their children's
teachers to keep folks learning
and not only are they free,
but there's more research studies done
on Khan Academy and Khan Academy Kids,
that almost all of those for pay products,
that frankly, are spending
probably more on marketing
than they are on product
development and content development
and research and development.
So get the word out, it's really a shame
that people aren't accessing these things,
or that they are paying for
things that are inferior,
frankly.
And but I wanna remind everyone,
the way that we're able to do this,
and kind of do what's
right on a principled level
is through donation.
So if you're benefiting you, your family
or if you just want other
kids around the country
and eventually the world to
benefit from Khan Academy Kids.
If you, your children, your students
or you want other people around the world
to benefit from Khan Academy.
Please think about making a donation
it makes a huge difference.
You know, one way to think about it,
if you were to go to
you know, a not as good
for pay product, it could
easily cost $10 a month
five dollars a month.
If you're able to support Khan Academy,
those types of levels.
It makes a difference and allows us
to support a lot lot more folks.
So thank you so much for joining
Caroline, thank you so much
you, Michael and your entire team.
Really amazing work and, you know,
thank you for dedicating
your life to this.
This is you did not have to do this,
this is not the way that
the world normally works.
But y'all, decided to do what's
right for frankly, humanity.
- Yeah, we're grateful
for the opportunity.
- Thanks, everyone, and
we'll see you all next week.
We have a lot of really
good guests next week.
We'll and you'll we'll be
sending out emails and stuff.
But you know, we have a really cool folks
like Angela Duckworth
and other folks next week
to talk about grit and resilience.
So as see y'all later,
have a great weekend
and take care of yourself.
Clearly Maria thinks I need to myself.
(laughs)